how's it going everybody exciting news
if you haven't heard Deadpool has a
surprise for us there's going to be
another movie coming out this Christmas
Fox had to recently make some changes to
other movies they had coming out so they
changed the release dates and this
pushed Deadpool up to December hi I'm
Deadpool the other jolly guy in a red
suit with a Lapworth sitting on now you
may have already found out about this
movie if you fall Ryan Reynolds on
Twitter he posted this photo of him the
other day
so if you did a little bit of digging
you may have found out about this movie
but as of yesterday we officially have a
title for it the title is called
the Deadpool before Christmas now
there's possibly some very exciting news
that could come with this movie I'm
going to talk about it in this video if
you're new to my channel I'm doing it
give away giving away a few copies of
Avengers infinity war on blu-ray some
special edition posters and some special
and then Mobilia all you have to do to
enter the giveaway is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so what is this
Deadpool movie about brace yourself well
it's actually going to be a different
version of Deadpool two different as in
it's going to be pg-13 and they're going
to change the story a bit
Oh Canada now this may make you shriek
and I certainly understand that but let
me explain why both of these things are
really good news for starters the
x-force perhaps in this movie the
x-force lives and this is how we get our
x-force movie it would certainly make
sense seeing as how the development
before the x-force movie has begun but
in Deadpool 2 we saw most of them die
now Deadpool could always go back in
time with cables time-travel device and
save more of the x-force than just Peter
but rewriting the ending could also save
them as well so that's really good news
but the most potentially exciting news
comes with the change to pg-13 and again
I realized that probably upsets some
people but think about why they're
changing it to pg-13 rumor has it that
they're doing this because they want
Deadpool to enter the MCU and Disney is
going to have a really hard time
incorporating a rated-r character into
their films Bob Iger said that Disney
could be open to do a rated-r movie but
the more likely option is that they're
going to dial down Deadpool just a
little bit off switch so a new Deadpool
movie being pg-13 is really good news
because it could be a transition for
Deadpool to go into the MCU and of
course for the younger viewers that
haven't seen it yet this could be your
chance the Fantastic Four and the x-men
are going into the MCU so it makes sense
to get Deadpool in there as well so
hopefully this is the start what do you
all think about this news for the
Deadpool before Christmas movie how
excited are you for Deadpool to enter
the MCU let me know what you think in
the comments below don't forget to
subscribe like and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so you can enter the giveaway
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]